now the investigation continues into a
shooting that left a woman dead and two
others hurt
this happened last night in a henderson
neighborhood near wigwam and green
valley parkways
that is where 8 news now reporter sally
jaramillo is live right now to tell us
what she's learned sally
david after speaking to many neighbors
they say it's unusual for something like
this to happen in their quiet
neighborhood but last night around 7 30
this area was packed with police
here's what i know about the shooting a
woman called 911 saying her
husband just shot two people however
when police and medical arrived
three people were found shot two men and
woman a 48-year-old woman was shot in
the face the victims were taken to
sunrise hospital
but the woman died the caller a
37-year-old woman
identified the shooter as 39-year-old
andrea andrews
and they just had a fight and andrews
left and she called friends for help
then
andrews returned neighbors who did not
want their identity disclosed
share reaction for the community to have
to see stuff like that it's scary
prayers and thoughts for that family on
both sides however it goes
you know in any situation with any kind
of domestic
violence you just whatever it is you
don't want this to be the outcome
andrew andrews was also injured in the
fight he has been booked
into the henderson detention center in
absentia on one count of domestic
battery one count of open murder
with a deadly weapon and two counts of
attempted murder with a deadly weapon
as for the woman who died we are still
waiting for her identity from the
coroner reporting live from henderson
sally jaramillo 8 news now